each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
well thank you for coming here this
morning it's my pleasure to introduce
nickel Swami who was with us for two
summers in the Cambridge lab and today
he's going to talk to us about his
dissertation work which focuses on using
language based techniques to secure
distribute web applications so please
thanks Ben so so my research has
generally addressed various aspects of
software quality recently I've been
focusing on security for web
applications today I'm going to talk
about security for a particular kind of
web two point O application this kind of
application is fairly common and that
logos I have up here are from some of
the most popular sites in the web but to
be clear what the kind of application
I'm talking about is our applications in
which users provide content and this
content is then shared among other users
via the website now you don't think of
these applications as enforcing
particularly strong kinds of security
policies so for instance on Wikipedia
most applications most pages are
publicly viewable publicly editable but
there are some pages that have simple
kinds of access control policies on them
but these kinds of web-based information
sharing applications are also being used
in organizations where information
sharing is where security is a really
top priority so for instance there's
this application called intelli pedia
which is Wikipedia in the CIA and it's
based on free software from from from
from Wikimedia it's the same it's pretty
much the same program and has about
3,600 users from 0 16 us Intel agencies
and the goal is to promote sharing of
information across the entire
organization but the tools they use are
pretty primitive so for instance with
Sean Dennehy is the person at the CIA
responsible for intellipedia and he says
that the tools they use are in their
Model T state
so there are many ways in which you
could imagine these things being
improved what I'm going to focus on is
is how you can make these applications
more secure so can you construct them in
a way that allows you to prove that they
correctly enforce security policies so
to that end I have three main
contributions the first is a new
language called se links or security
enhanced links targets multi-tiered web
applications and allows you to enforce
user-defined security policies
end-to-end I formalize the core of this
language in a in a framework in a in a
calculus called fable which is a system
f with labels and I prove the sound I've
showed that fable is quite expressive
that you can use it to encode a wide
range of user-defined policies and it
allows you to prove that the encoding
czar correct that they satisfy certain
high level security goals we have some
application experience are currently our
biggest application is something called
se wiki that you could think of as a
prototype of a next-generation intelli
pedia and we have some other
applications as well so what I'm going
to do for the rest of this talk is first
tell you a little bit very very little
bit how how intellipedia works today and
then tell you about how we'd like it to
work and then spend the bulk of the top
telling you about how we actually went
out to build this thing so intellipedia
is not actually one application there
are multiple applications so in them in
the military there are actually separate
networks that are classified to handle
the data of different classification
levels so there's a top secret Network
and a secret network and they completely
separate and there's an Intel apevia
that runs in the top secret network and
one that runs in the secret network and
documents in the top secret network can
then point to documents in the secret
Network but not vice versa users with
the appropriate clearance level can log
into each Network top secret user gets
the top secret documents the secret user
gets the secret documents and as you
might expect the secret user can't log
into the top secret Network and get
those documents but somewhat
counter-intuitively a top secret user
can't also directly log in here he can't
follow hyperlinks his session at the
top-secret Intel appiah is not the same
as a session of the secret until appear
yes log in log out log in separately
through a separate network and so on so
this is clearly less than optimal but
and the question is why do they actually
do it this way so and there there are
many reasons perhaps but the one that I
think is is most significant is that
there isn't a way of constructing an
application today that is I can be
trusted to handle data of multiple
classification levels and and prove that
it that it doesn't inadvertently leak
information so yep yeah but why do they
have so the links are there because
presumably it it gives an indication to
the user that they could that there is
some information out there that they
could then log out and go fetch it from
somewhere so this also leads to other
kinds of problems this isolation between
top secret and secret is not a is not
set in stone so you typically have
top-secret data that has to be
declassified and downgraded and right
now that's a pretty much manual process
as a release officer that looks at these
documents scrubs out pieces of it copies
it into the next into the lower
classification level network and this
leads to all kinds of other problems and
now you have multiple versions of the
same document and you don't know if you
know if it's difficult to keep them in
sync and so on so what we'd like to do
instead is to is to have a more fine
grain structure for for security
policies in the system so first of all
we want to have a application that's
that's clear to handle top secret and
secret documents and this where away
gets rid of this problem users can
follow links and interact the same
application we also won't have more
fine-grained sharing so instead of
having documents at different
classification levels fragments of
documents could be a different
classification level and the application
has to filter out the the appropriate
part of the of the of the document for
serving it to the secret user but the
top secret user gets to see the whole
thing now there are other kinds of
security policies that we might also
enforcement system like this so
accurately tracking provenance
information making sure that downgrading
ground grades are performed correctly
ensuring that crypto protocols are used
properly well in this talk I'm really
just going to focus on this this access
control framework there's one other
thing that I'd like to talk about though
which is in this web setting there are
some web specific threats that we have
to take care of so in particular there's
the things like cross-site scripting
attacks so these are really common and
this kind of web two point of
application is particularly susceptible
to it and they're hard to defend against
and they're dangerous too so whatever
solution we come up with must be able to
protect against things like cross-site
scripting attacks too okay so now that
we have these these security
requirements we want to go out and build
software that actually implements these
security policies correctly so typically
security enforcement mechanisms are are
often not implemented are often not
implemented correctly so things like
access control bypasses or error
handling code and inadvertently leaks
messages and error messages leaks
information in error messages and so on
so one solution is to use language based
techniques to ensure that we have proper
enforcement so we either have custom
languages or program analyses that
ensure that you actually implement a
security policy correctly but the
problem with this is that they typically
specialized towards a certain kind of
policy so you might have an analysis
that tracks tainting or you might ensure
that access control is done correctly
and what we want instead is a more
general framework we want a language for
expressing security policies in their
enforcement that satisfies three goals
so first we want to ensure that the
policy enforcement mechanism cannot be
circumvented the second is that given a
security policy and its enforcement
mechanism we want to be able to prove
that certain high level security goals
are satisfied that that Alice never
learns Bob's data and third we want all
this to be fairly modular so if you want
enforce an access control at a
provenance and an information flow
policy all in the same application this
framework should be allowed should allow
you to do all that even though these
have multiple different sorts of
concerns so towards that
I have for contributions the first is
security enhanced links and like I
mentioned se links is a language for
enforcing security policies in a
multi-tier web application it's an
extension of the links programming
language which is developed at edinburgh
by phil warner's group and the
extensions to links are essentially two
main components there's a a new type
checker to ensure that security policies
are properly enforced and it's a new
code generator that allows se links code
to be compiled to stored procedures that
can run in the database that allow you
to enforce cross to your policies the
second is the formalism of se links
called fable we proved it sound and we
showed that it's that it's fairly
expressive so we have in coatings of
access control policies in multiple
styles we have Providence policies
information flow controls which are both
static and dynamic we can show that it
can enforce stack inspection policies
and security automaton based policies
the last one is is particularly
interesting because there are some
results that show that once you can
reliably enforce automaton policies then
there's a wild class of safety
properties that you can enforce and for
each of these in coatings we proved
useful properties about them the third
key result is this technique we call
browser enforced embedded policies or
beep and beep is particularly
interesting in this context because it
leverages collaboration between client
and server to address cross-site
scripting attacks so we have a
customized a set of we've customized a
few web browsers to allow this
collaboration to take place and beep can
be used to perfectly detect all exercise
attacks with this collaboration and our
se links compiler produces beep enabled
code
sure I'll describe it more in detail
later but but in short what it is is
that ay ay ay users can attack each
other's browsers by inserting JavaScript
that can steal authentication tokens
from another browser or or other kinds
of things as well can maybe have
JavaScript worms that replicate so but
i'll give you a detailed example how
this works but the short answer is that
process it uses attack each other via
the browser link cross-site scripting
attacks did not exist yeah so would you
is there still some reason for doing
whatever you're doing oh poor doing beep
yes we're doing the band you're all
you're all the others are not
necessarily be a cross-site scripting
specific beep is the one that addresses
cross-site scripting so the other
techniques could be used in context
which are not web specific at all
general information flow stack
inspection access control you could use
it in any context really but to get it
to work in them in the web context we
must be able to address cross-site
scripting and that's where it becomes
and so the the final contribution is is
application experience we have this se
wiki application it's about 3500 lines
of a CBS code and it enforces three
kinds of policies in the in-a-day a
compositional ways so first there's a
fine-grained access control that I've
been talking about there's also
provenance tracking and there's an
interesting a cross to your stack
inspection policy that I'll try to
describe briefly later we've also
developed an e-commerce application
we've actually ported it from links to
show that se links is not just targeted
towards these web two point of
applications you can also build more
traditional web applications in it as
well ok so the kind of application I'm
talking about just bird which is
probably quite familiar to most of you
is is three-tiered web applications in
which there's JavaScript that runs in
the client there's
code that runs in the server that's a
j2ee dotnet PHP something like that and
the client and server communicate via
say posting HTML forms or Ajax and so on
the server and the database communicate
via say JDBC or send by having sequel
queries that appear here that I've been
communicated the database now
programming these applications are can
be tricky because there's multiple
languages and these non-standard
interfaces between them and analyzing
them is also difficult because of this
so here's where links comes in so links
is a multi-tier web programming language
and the way links works is like this
there's you write a single links program
and the compiler links compiler
interpreters there are their
declarations in the links program that
say this code is was running the client
or this code as opposed to running the
soap in the database and the compiler
dense then compiles part of it to
JavaScript part of it is interpreted the
server and sequel queries that are
embedded in links are compiled to sequel
and now the interface between the tears
is not instead of HTML forms and so on
is just function call and return so it's
a easier for us it's important because
this is easier to analyze the entire
application so as he links it has two
main components so there's a new type
system that allows you to enforce
user-defined policies and the way this
works is that there's some high-level
policy that you want to enforce and
software so the expert rights at
enforcement policy which which maps high
level security concepts to program
operations things like how the policy
should be enforced with functions are
applied and so on and then the type
checker ensures that the program is
consistent with this enforcement policy
that all program operations are
consistent with this specification the
second thing is this new code generator
which compiles enforcement policy code
to stored procedures that are in the
database and database queries then
include calls to these stored procedures
to ensure that to ensure that the same
policies in force both in the server and
the database so here's how at a high
level how a user defined policies
enforced and I see links there are three
steps to it
is first a security policy specified by
associating program data and actions
with with customizable security labels
now these security labels are just
program expressions the user gets to
pick what these are what these
expressions are the semantics of these
expressions are not baked into the type
system so to specify the semantics of
these labels there's a special part of
the program called an enforcement policy
that defines how labeled data is allowed
to be used and these label data or these
protected values can only be constructed
and destructed in a manner consistent
with this enforcement policy so what I'm
going to do now is is to show you how a
simple access control policy can be
encoded in messy links so the first
thing you do is to specify a language of
security labels so you could have labels
like high or low and so on to specify
confidentiality levels the next thing
you do is to protect data by allowing a
label to appear in its type so for
instance int X is unprotected data it's
just it's type as int it contains no
label it can be used in any way by the
application y on the other hand has a
label el in it that defines how its how
it should be used its protected and L
defines how it should be used these
labels can be arbitrary so you could the
policy designer could pick access
control list with two user names in it
for instance and in general this does
not just have to be a valid the labels
are not values they can be expressions
so data with a protected type as has a
type that looks like this a tea with an
e in curly brackets where a defines the
security policy yeah thank you me is
like a brand new verse is so uh it's
side-effect free program expressions yep
labels include labels yes so that which
actually turns out to be interesting in
things like say provenance policies
where the the provenance information is
itself secure so you might want to
protect the the provenance information
with it with scone policies
so before we can enforce an access
control policy the first thing we need
to do is to be able to produce high
integrity user credentials in a way that
these credentials can't be forged by
another part of the application so here
we have a simple policy function that
does a login it takes two arguments a
username and a password we check the
password and if this succeeds we get a
value of type user cred and the unique
thing the the distinctive thing about a
policy function is that it has access to
the special operators label and
unlabeled which I'll show you later that
allows you to construct and destruct
labeled values so this label operator is
applied to the user credential to
produce a value of this forum user cred
hi so this says that this is a high
integrity user credential and it can
only be produced by functions like this
that have this policy qualifier on it it
is me from making all my functions ok so
the policy functions are trusted we have
to verify that these actually do the
right thing so our proofs of our
encoding is being correct actually have
to analyze these to make sure that they
do the right thing so if you were to do
that then you'd have to prove that your
entire program is correct so the point
is to keep your policy where it'll be
small so for instance in our our
non-interference proof for information
flow we have to prove that the policies
actually propagate dependencies
correctly so with respect to us sorry in
this case that this is some trusted
authentication function instead of just
checking the password you could do some
sick you know signature checks or you
know whatever it is so map it to your
high level notion of user and user
credentials and you have to show that
this actually does you know does the
right thing so for instance if we had
the label we produce the credential in
the failure case then then that wouldn't
be great
right so yeah it's a human review item
that currently we have hand proofs that
this works right and I'm at the moment
working on a framework that allows you
to compile these two declarations and
and allow you to try to do things
semi you know partially automated okay
so once we have user credentials we can
then define an access control policy
using this this function access which is
which takes three arguments the first
argument is the user credential produced
by log in the second argument is an
access control list and the program the
the policy designer can instantiate this
access control list with a list of user
IDs let's say and there's and the data
itself is data of any type alpha that's
protected by the access control list so
this is a dependent type here with the
saying that the third argument is
protected by the label it appears in the
second argument just like so in the body
we check that you as mentioned in the
access control list if it is then as in
the log in case there's this the there's
an unlabeled operator so label and
unlabeled are the two operators that
policy function is allowed to use that
strips the label off of data and exposes
a value of type alpha to the application
yep chris is a member
who can find them % another policy
functions so it it it doesn't actually
have to be a policy function because it
doesn't rely on this on label and label
but in order to verify that that access
is correct you have to know something
about members like this come
automatically that's right yeah and
intention is in practice this is not
just a member check it's a call out to
some higher level policy that's you know
defining user credentials and maybe it's
written in some trust management
framework or something can I an
arbitrary code now that's not policy
coca-cola is next yes okay don't you
have this line prom in information flow
which is that once your unlabeled the
data yeah do anything that you want
right that's right the rest of the car
is broken them yes so this is a simple
as control policy which we don't place
restrictions on how information is used
once its points access is granted there
are other ways in which I'll show you
briefly that you can actually encode
information flow policies in this that
address this problem that even though
arbitrary application code can call this
function that we actually track flows
throughout the application so the point
where this is that it's a really simple
encoding for a really simple policy and
we think that's a good thing that you
know it's a very common thing that you
might want to try to do and it has an
almost trivial sort of encoding yes how
are you perish in the basic color I
meant to say this earlier sorry um the
distinction is that base types are in
purple and expressions are in green so X
so the these expressions that appear in
the types are distinguished from the
base types of selves so high user
credits on base type and high is an
expression that appears in the time
it's a user-defined thing so user
credits is some way so this could be
actually instantiated two integers or
two to public keys or or whatever you
whatever way in which you want to
enforce it for your language is an
operator there is a good operator your
language yes and what is named Barry
members is fun all the green stuff is
just one yet okay let's label with
something yeah is the program allowed to
meet the bits of interest after are my
blood first it has only first it must go
via one of these functions to actually
get okay so this is so the point is that
is that this is really you know almost
trivial but the thing is with something
like this you can you can begin to do
interesting things so uh so suppose you
had a program like this that was uh that
you know there's a login that produces a
user credential and then you open files
from the file system that gives you an
access control list and a file handle
and the types here indicate that the
access control list is a label and the
file handle is a file that's protected
by that access control list now suppose
you wanted a way to read files out of
this read strings out of this out of
this file handle so we can give the
library function read line that type
over there and this type is a little bit
interesting unlike the the tie
polymorphism we had earlier this is a
different is the kind of polymorphism
that we call phantom label polymorphism
so what this means is that red line is a
function that takes a labeled file where
L is any label and produces a string
with that same label and the L is an
implicit type parameter that it doesn't
actually have to be passed in at runtime
or doesn't have to actually be
instantiation instantiated either so uh
or we can infer the instantiations I
should say so if we call read line and
passing and fh as a filehandle at this
point we can infer that the
instantiation of L is a CO and we
produce a a string that's labeled by the
same access control list as as the
next suppose we wanted to print this
strength to the to the terminal then we
can have functions like print string
that have that type on it that say you
can only print unsecured or unprotected
strings to the terminal it has a type
string our unit and this allows us to
say if the program can take expressions
like this it said print string of line
that's detected statically and instead
the programmer has to has to interpose
an access control check before actually
printing the string because this is
dependent typing we we get a little bit
more precision as well so you can ensure
that the association between access
control lists and the data that they
protect is is always coherent so for
instance if we had another access
control list around and the application
tried to spoof the policy by passing in
the wrong access control list then we
can catch that as well so that was
access control so I'm just going to show
you a little bit about how we can do
other kinds of policies as well so
information flow for instance so so the
we don't require the expressions to
appear in types to be values it can be
arbitrary expressions so there's a
framework of type conversions that we
use to allow you to do things like this
so for instance you can have a function
plus that takes two labeled integers L&M
integers that are labeled with LNM and
produces an integer that's labeled with
Reese upper bound of the two and lob
here is just a another user-defined
function and then the type system can
actually do these reductions it can
produce an int lob low-high to an int hi
to actually and do this statically so we
can use this to enforce a static
information flow policy we can also do
dynamic enforcement by a type refinement
so for instance if we had a a a print
function that that had this type that
said you can only print a a string that
has a low label on it and we had some X
that was labeled by some arbitrary naval
L then we can reflect the runtime track
of l with low in the type so in the true
branch of this if track we can actually
prove that
print X meets the meets the requirements
of the type disappointment we have
another matter if you did the policy
check than the refinement of curves if
you did the label if you did the
equality check then in the true branch
or we refine L to be true love you not
write this goes way and you would have
to do you would write the if l equals
low yeah and the point is that you know
you can use runtime checks like this to
establish evidence that cannot
necessarily be proved by a type
convertibility by the type system so why
do we choose this design for SE links so
first is the first reason that also all
security code is in a separate
enforcement policy so you know that to
reason about the security the entire
application you just look at the policy
and this also makes it easy to interface
with some high-level policy engine I
mentioned earlier that you could call
out to some trust management framework
to actually to the policy checks the
type system is doesn't know anything
about security it just allows you to
ensure that you have complete mediation
and that protected data is only
accessible via the policy and with
dependent types it allows you to
associate policy and data and you can
never break this association unless
without going by to the policy and this
this setup has allowed us to formalize
it and we've proved that its sound and
that it's relatively easy to prove
properties about our encoding so I'm
just going to give you a short flavor of
a small part of the static semantics of
this language that i can i can give you
an idea of what sort of security
properties we prove so the basic
judgment is in a context gamma and
expression e has a type t and this
judgment is parametrized by by a context
a color see that tells you whether
you're typing policy code or application
code we have a little bit of syntax
these these circular brackets to delimit
a policy code from application code and
what this says is that when you type the
body of a policy function you type it in
the context with Paul on it
and this is a this we have to be careful
that when that application code does not
mistaken they gain the privilege of off
of policy code so propagating these
brackets around is a little bit tricky
and then this unlabeled function has a
very simple rule as well so if you have
an expression e with this T of e prime
as a type on it unlabeled strips the
expression the the label often gives you
an expression with the type T so it's
pretty simple but that's all I needed to
show you about this type system to
actually state a little bit about this
theorem so we formalized a property for
access control that we call nan
observability and typically a
correctness property for access control
is quite is it refers to a a specific
execution and it's something like every
access of a function is every access of
some projected data is preceded by a
call to an authorization function
instead what we wanted to do is to have
some kind of extensional property for
access control so the so we have this
property called on observability that
i'm going to try to state and have to
leave out a couple of the of the of the
details but I hope I get the main point
across so what this says is that there's
an application program e that's typed in
an application context that's what makes
it an application program and it refers
to a boolean variable X that's protected
by some access control list and then you
have some user with a user ID that's not
allowed to access XO user is not
mentioned with this access control list
then what we can say is that if this
user observes two executions of e one in
which X is true and one which ex is
false then these two executions are in
disagreeable but this is a strong by
simulation between the truth so this is
quite similar to a non-interference
property in fact it implies not
interference but it's a little bit
stronger it requires new treat X
abstractly that you're that egain is no
information about exit hole is the
timing the timing and termination
sensitive property so the proof of this
property goes quite a lot like a proof
of a say value abstraction property for
a polymorphic language so the
distinction between this and
non-interference is a little bit subtle
and I'd be happy to talk about this more
in person later fact that the
environment is continuing that's right
yeah so the the other side condition is
that e does not contain in itself some
other policy function that lets it strip
off data in a way that you didn't expect
ok so now I'm going to switch gears a
little bit and tell you about this this
document management system that we built
in SE links so so se wiki enforces a
fine-grained composite policy in
documents there's a group based access
control on fragments of a document so
you can associate policies with little
pieces of documents there's a Providence
policy that tracks various operations
and documents or documents are copied
from other documents we can we can
preserve dependency information if if
elements of a document are produced by
computations and we can track program
slices to allow you to to show you where
this where this information came from
and then we have this a cross tier stack
inspection policy where it allows us to
limit where information releases occur
in the program so you're not allowed to
actually download information unless
you're in the context of a privileged
function on the stack and hour
compilation technique allows this to be
encode allows us to be enforcement
across to your way so we can actually
pass the the call stack off the database
to enforce this policy correctly a
couple of screenshots from from se wiki
it's basically a standard Ricky that has
a lot of the features that you expect
you could edit pages search for pages
and we have a tutorial up there that
guides you through the features of this
application the interesting thing is
that it has these two kinds of labels
these access control labels and these
provenance labels and every page is
associated with you know fragments of a
page are associated with labels so in
this particular case we have a fairly
complicated label model in which over
here we have a textual representation of
the label and this label applies to the
entire page but fragments of the
document also have their own labels
yeah so the way in which we represent
these documents in the programming
language is using a value of this type
and this type is a is basically an NRI
tree where the leaves are strings that
store the content of the document and
some sub trees are protected by security
labels so here protected is a
constructor that takes two arguments the
first argument is a document label and
the second argument is a document that's
protected by that label so this is a
dependent e-type pair for the protected
constructor and the point here is that
doc lab is just some user-defined type
there's not anything specific in the in
the type system that forces you to use
doc lab but once we have have data like
this we have to be able to store it in
the database that means we have to be
able to store the labels themselves in
the database queries and updates of the
database must respect the security
policy and we want to do this in a way
that bulk data processing is still
efficient we don't want to do everything
in the server we actually want to
enforce these policies in the database
so the way we do this in SE links is we
start we start by giving a type to it to
a table that looks like this where this
is the type of the label dark table that
contains label documents that's the
table name and it's type is a tuple it's
a 3-2 pool where the first component is
an ID which is just a primary key that's
the integer there is the second argument
is a the second field is a label oh
there's a typo here this should be doc
lab sorry and that protects the data in
the third column which is a string
protected by the second column and so
what we do is we have we have postgres
the Postgres database has a feature of
custom data type extensions so we have
extensions to postgres that allows the
store se links values like label in the
database and now that we have a type for
this for the
table we can actually enforce the policy
such that queries of this table respect
the labeling policy so first so in SE
links the way our tables are viewed is
as a list of tuples and queries of the
day of the table are expressed as list
comprehensions so suppose we want to
write a query that selected all the
documents from that from from the
database that match a particular string
safe food the way this looks and i see
links is like this so you have a a table
decoration LD that's our label document
from from the previous slide and then
this list comprehension says that for
each row in the in the LD table return
all the rows in this part that matched
the where clause now the where clause
has to be is a little bit interesting
because the data itself is protected we
can't inspect the data directly we have
to first call out to a policy function
that grants us the privilege to access
the data before running a regular
expression check on it so the way you
write that is to actually in line a
function call to access passing in the
user credential the label and the data
that you want to protect if this check
succeeds then you can run it you can
match it against the regular expression
so this we think this is good because
whether you're accessing data running
queries against the database or just
doing other actions in the in the
program you have this it's the same
model for enforcing the security policy
it's just calling a function at the
right point it doesn't matter whether
it's in a where clause or anywhere else
in the application it looks the same but
in order to do this you have to be a
little bit careful that to get
reasonable performance we can't execute
this entire query in the server we
actually have to execute this in the
database so our solution is to compile
these access these enforcement policies
like access to stored procedures in the
database and then sequel queries and
call out these procedures and we have we
have some experiments that show that we
can actually recover reasonable
performance using the scheme it's about
an order of magnitude better than
actually enforcing it all on the server
so and it also allows for novel policies
to be enforced so it's not yet welding
mayra understanding the
there's a particular property being
checked that some function call must be
made before some access to some data
there is done you are checking this
using time system techniques right yeah
so so there i mean it's it's it's not
flow sensitive right i mean what you
have to show that along all execution
paths where the access is done that the
permission function should we call so
don't you we actually do that we do
check it on all hall passes function is
called i see but in this simple box that
i showed you once you accessed it then
you're free to do with it whatever you
want once you get access to the data
then you know you can send the
university that's what you want so but
for example let's say that there was a
function that for forgetting access
granted yeah or does not grant it right
then later on you try to access the data
then you have to keep track of the fact
whether the access was branded or not so
you have to have some kind of floor
sensitivity going around there right so
the data is initially at a protected
type would say int with a label on it
yes is functional languages also
actually insane really function is okay
even if even if there were references
and you try the reference had a label on
it so you weren't allowed to dereference
it and then once you did an access
control check you would and it succeeded
then you would get a reference without a
and access control without a label on it
and then you can dereference it as many
times as you want but if you wanted to
enforce an information for a policy then
the policy does not actually return an
unlabeled value it returns a value that
has a type with some label on it that
that tracks the flows let's say is the
least upper bound of the labels that
contribute it to constructing that
reference so I don't have a full
encoding of an information flow policy
on these slides but we do have one in
our paper and I I'd be happy to talk to
you about how that actually works
so the way this this so to give you a
brief idea but how this compilation
technique works is that that that list
comprehension that we had on the
previous slide that that selected values
under this table is compiled to sequel
that looks like this so it's a it
contains a call to a function which is
the access function passing in values
from the program and then the access
function itself is compiled to a stored
procedure that looks like this and and
the store procedure is in is in PL PG
sequel and this call goes out to here so
it has the same model as it would have
in the in the database in the in the
server except that now the actress
function is actually resident in the
database as PL BGC okay so so much for
the database so we also have to worry
about securing client interactions so
right now we have no way of limiting
what code the client run so our
restriction is that label data cannot be
sent directly to the client so we have a
simple analysis that ensures that prior
to releasing label data at the time
there is an appropriate policy check
that goes yep in the lane so you have
special source or in the lane in the
programming language to access the
database yes okay so that way you
guaranteed that you can't find a select
that does not have that little access a
check that's right your queries are
written in this list comprehension
language that we typed ray that's right
right the other thing that's that's that
is something that we're interested in is
that once you have functions like this
are in the database you can associate
this function with a view on the table
so all suppose you had some other
application that was going to access the
table it has to respect this policy as
well so we can have some kind of
protection for untyped check code to
so about the client so we can't actually
verify the client runs the code that we
expected to write so we don't handle
label data to the client there's a
couple of ideas that we're beginning to
explore that that use a cryptographic
primitives to actually either encrypt or
sign data before you send it to the
client so that you can enforce
confidentiality and integrity policies
even when you can't trust the code
that's run by the client but clients can
also attack each other and this is where
cross-site scripting attacks come in and
we have this big technology to protect
against this so here's our cross-site
scripting attack works in in our SE wiki
application yet the first bullet one of
the first of all they said once the data
leaves the program there is sent to the
web browser it has to be unplayable yes
and so now we're going to talk about the
fact that you have unlabeled data in
your browser you may want some other wow
there's something enterprise so even if
you have only unlabeled data and in
browser an attacker can can steal label
data from that he's not allowed to see
and I'm going to show you how that data
links the program increase the client
browser yeah it's already ugly right so
that will protect let me show you this
attack though that shows you how a user
can add can escalate privileges using a
cross-site scripting so a documents are
like this there are some top secret
component and some secret component
where the top secret is purple a secret
user comes along and the top secret
portion is filtered out and he gets just
the secret component what if this user
turns out to be an attacker you can
insert a script into this part of the
document that says get the top secret
component of the document and reload the
browser at evil sitecom passing in this
top secret data in the query string and
then save these changes and these
changes get saved to the database with
that malicious script in the secret
component a top secret user comes along
and now this portion of the document is
not filtered out it's over here the
script runs in the data in the browser
and the top secret data is forwarded to
evil sitecom so so we have to have a way
of ensuring that that that these either
that these scripts never gets Jeff
saving the database or if they do that
they never get run in the browser so the
typical defense to this is to actually
filter content at the server to ensure
that these scripts are never say for the
database but this is difficult because
parsing HTML is and JavaScript reliably
is very difficult that malformed HTML is
always it's commonly accepted by
browsers and filtering this out is not
easy so our insight is that the right
place to do this filtering is at the
browser so because browsers detect
JavaScript perfectly so what we do is we
filter scripts in the browser so what we
did was to customize a few web browsers
to filter out cross-eyed scripts and we
have customizations for Safari Conqueror
opera has a way of supporting this
without customizations and we have some
support in Firefox as well and when
passing an HTML document the browser
calls out to a special policy hook
function that decides if a JavaScript
that encounters is a good script or a
bad script and the browser loads the
JavaScript only if the script authorizes
it these are relatively small changes to
these browsers for for instance it's
less than thousand lines of code in
Safari that's about 350,000 lines of
code I mean can't the attacker a
hyperlink or a button or something that
but but that script in its query string
would have to have some JavaScript to
actually fetch the secret contents from
the other part from another sub tree in
the document and so that script would
never run even when you clicked on it
that script would not be allowed to run
should I be sufficient now write an
image tag tells you go out get this file
there's no JavaScript needed but it's
not going to find its its of uh it's get
another portion of the same often I'll
which you can put anything you want in a
query string for each other or for an
image and then we load and then that
image would have the top secret
component in the top secret user's
browser which is fine right we want
some way to actually get the component
and then reload the browser and send the
data somewhere else trill lessons as
Parliament site URL contained that top
secret portion I think that's right oh
wait for Hankins yeah not sure I
understand we need insight you have a so
to speak then as part of its URL yeah as
that you know strength which comes from
a dog but it doesn't have toxic
resourcing wants to get the top secret
sauce so you have to have there's no way
to construct that URL unless you
actually can do this right right okay so
we can we can filter out these scripts
in the browser but we still have to have
a way of telling the browser what a good
script is and what a bad script is so
this is where the server comes in so
it's easy to for the server to identify
what a good script is in what a bad
script is so we have two ways of doing
this either the server specifies a
whitelist which is a cryptographic hash
of all the good scripts in the page or a
blacklist where all the dynamic content
of the page is sandbox into us into a
subtree of the of the HTML page and the
browser then checks to see that a good
script matches the whitelist or if it's
a bad script if it runs in that sandbox
then it doesn't it doesn't get run and
we can show that we've showed that for
the top 30 websites we've retrofitted
them with these policies and the
slowdown is six percent on average the
attacker from sending a open a slash kid
yeah so this is a so the way English
this actually works is haven't showed
the full encoding here so essentially
there's a way of taking that's the user
content treating it as a string and then
assigning it to the sub to the subtree
in a way that this splitting is not
possible there are details in our paper
there's a there's a way of transforming
this dynamic content into a string such
that that's not possible
there's a feature called innerhtml in
these dorms that just including is yeah
all browsers have this way of their two
modes in which they pass it content
either an XML mode or in HTML mode and
we can use the XML mode to ensure that
the splitting never happens for example
you gave before you want to Centrum let
us the entire the time we did the user
portion yet any subtle strip whether
it's top secret or a secret / al you
yeah so in which case you could use this
policy instead it's a sign if you want
to have scripts that run in the dynamic
content you could use the whitelist
policy to say well only these ones that
are in the dynamic content are good the
others are bad no there is to enable
scraped some particular car touching
distance of users which is kind of
difficult in with the server knows what
script it needs for normal application
functionality and the rest is black mr.
yeah it's also our two policies it seems
like white just a simple way of doing it
why don't you just do that white why you
froze into the complexity of what seems
like a Messier unless a systematic
approach so to do I think a lot of pages
actually structured this way so if you
want a retrofit your application to do
something like this then that's the way
you know this would be an easy way to do
it if you're constructing your
application from scratch say using SE
links where you had some tools support
to actually produce these hashes then do
it this way the other thing with this is
that computing these hashes in
javascript is a little bit expensive so
we have native support to actually
completely compute these hashes so it
turns out that with these hashes it's
not six percent it's more like ten
percent so for a legacy yeah so we
actually have a tool that does that that
goes over and producing these hashes so
we just give you two ways of doing it at
the point is to say that there's it's
programmable and that this hook is also
just JavaScript you get to do what you
wanted yeah right catch the and you're
the one was there
so if there's any script that appears in
this black in this within the sandbox
when you're loading the script the
browser walks up the tree and if it
encodes if it encounters a sandbox node
it says this is a bad script I'm not
going to load it make sure that anyone
have any spirits an opinion super mellow
yes yep sure I don't get any scriptures
right why static whitelist will be now
for the majority of applications well I
think this is in general you know this
is more general so you could you could
make this work for for for all
applications you can if you can reliably
identify all your scripts then that's
good there are occasions that generate
script at one time which means to have
update divided less them so speaking
p.m. perhaps know maybe there's
legitimate threesome cookout user
provides premise for application like
Facebook say yeah and then if you were
able to sanitize the scripts and figure
out that they did the right thing you'd
add them to the whitelist yeah yeah I
know that yeah so but you know so it's a
trade-off if you had a way of sanitizing
then you use it this you do that
otherwise if you don't then you say you
don't own the script wireless flows and
then call functions that I'm here at
other firms so that once the script is
trusted its trusted transitivity so any
script that it allows is also permitted
to run so this is something that could
be you know something that we might want
to program as evals and yeah so so
there's you know it certainly does but
more browser support you could try to do
things like rewrite these scripts that
they've every time they do any value
check something as well but the point of
this was to say that with small changes
you could you could go reasonable then
sing something trust addendum trifles
calling yeah so more browser support our
point here would say with small changes
thousand lines of code you can actually
do interesting things but if you want to
extend the browser have a more
programming
interface that allows you to produce
this transitivity requirement is a bolt
include the browser and the trusted
computing base I mean you know if I was
insane you came to me and said oh all
you do is add more stuff to the browser
sound like we're we're sort of
proceeding along the cap that's going to
lead to success it's a good question but
I mean I think if you're trying to
enforce rich policies then forcing you
to do it only other server is your hat
your hands are somewhat tied there's
only so much you can do if you want to
do enrich things that you need the
browser to help you out a little bit and
the current that's sort of a bizarre
statement really when the browser
resides on untrusted platform yeah and
you know how do you know you can trust
any aspect of the browser well this is
being used to protect a the user so if
he wants to run a bad browser then he
bit you know he's harming himself right
i mean you can imagine sort of goodness
hello pedia that it's used to protect
the information that the NSA doesn't
want leaked it's not protecting the user
as much as this protecting the owner of
the content yeah in that case you need
the owner needs to take safeguards
against it so not yes you would probably
do more at the server but that i'm
talking about policies that are intended
to protect the users you know
authentication tokens and the users data
in that case you can enforce it at the
browser because it's in the users
interest to run a good browser there's
an ad is room yeah great user right yeah
I'm good you turn right but there's
another third there's a third party in
there which is one that owns the
information that you also have to worry
about such as these two users that are
important yeah I understand the scenario
in swim but yeah just sort of i think i
mean i agree this is this is tough and
maybe in this case you have to have some
kind of way of ensuring you use drm to
ensure maybe that the user the silver
intros the user runs the right browser
but that has its own problem
India maybe since sometimes the
alternative is that you're right custom
client-side display out from this camera
vision right ok what are the changes are
you going to get that right maybe it's
good to use something and rise of where
you know where the scripting executions
happening I don't know Oh sir it is a
hard problem but I just sort of worried
that so ready to evolve and develop Java
it's really hard to be assured that you
thought all a little rough inches yeah I
agree so so that's pretty much it i'm
just going to wrap up with some talk
about next steps and so as we've been
talking about Richard client policies in
some way either by using crypto or by
having more browser support and force
other kinds of security policies I think
policy composition is an interesting
problem that that you have to worry
about can we specify policies
automatically I've been assuming that
these labels are on documents somehow
magically can we actually analyze the
content of documents to come up with a
reasonable initial labeling to say that
this contains sensitive information that
should be labeled hi maybe using some
machine learning techniques apply fable
two other domains so this calculus can
be applied in other contexts maybe
retrofitting legacy apps or os-level
information controls and then finally
some work that I've just started doing
is to act mechanize the matter theory of
able to prove have semi automation in
proving that these policy functions are
correct so wrap up I told you about
fable a formal language foreign force
user defined policies lynx plus faible
plus our postgres equal compiler is se
links and we have some application
experience I've told you but I see wiki
we also have this other application SE
wine store that's our project website
where you can try our demos and the
papers that are on there and here are
some other projects that I've worked on
that I'd be happy to talk about in
person later that's it
other questions
second time that's a little bit of them
since they're one thing you hear from
people work on information plans that
they have to be careful about cooker
channels that the access control
mechanisms themselves can't be used as a
cover channel yet and when wondering if
you run into this this problem with
labeling yeah so this work actually
looks at that problem so we where if you
have access control checks that can
modify the state of the policy then you
have to be worried about how you can
leak information about secret program
data through the state of the policy
itself so so these kinds of policies
this kind of enforcement in this
language RX can also be encoded in fable
so the point with fable and SE links is
that it's a very just simple primitives
dependent types basically allow you to
encode all these things so we have yet
to explore actually implement an
encoding of RX in the system but it's
something that we'd like to try to do
remember as a child when they write
access control functions like like the
access thing you should just watch out
for channels yeah so at this point we
have hand proofs that they don't leak
they don't leak information through
covert channels but ideally we'd like to
also have some specification of a
security goal that we'd like to prove
and then show somehow maybe
semi-automatically that it does the
right thing yeah how much work is it
writing these policies using a ceiling
so writing the policies themselves I
think are relatively easy for the kinds
of policies that we looking at the pot
that's that is not so hard if you're
trying to enforce access control
policies where it's only an access
control check and you don't care how the
information flows wants your granted
authorization that's also pretty easy
when it get it gets hard when you have
to do things like track information
flows even you know through computations
and that is hard because you have to
interpose these policy checks at these
critical points so it's something that
we're we're working on in a sense that
we'd like to be able to take a program
and transform it so that inserts the
appropriate policy tricks and so it's
not easy at that point at this point to
be able to do it flow based policies but
it's possible to do then we have some
experience doing it so we think that
rewriting is a is a way to go forward
always work with the work on Jim yeah so
so jiff jiff bakes in non-interference
and information flow policies into the
type system so if you want information
flow you have to buy into it you know
all the way so you have to care about it
implicit channels for everywhere so my
perspective is that you know there are
certain critical parts of your code
where you do care about information
flows and you know maybe your your
crypto libraries or your downgrading
functions and right there you should
probably have very precise information
flow controls but for the rest of your
application probably you know you should
have some incremental way of
constructing these things so se links
gives you a way to start say with access
control have a basic level of security
and then to iteratively refine and and
approach gifs style information below
policies for the parts of the code did
you care about just to follow from that
so I can your point about you thanks
Emily do you get any advantages from it
language uh so i would say that surged
it certainly is extremely powerful but
there's another language that's called
flow camel that also does makes an
information flow and does label
inference so you don't actually have to
write down types and Jeff does a small
amount of label inference but only
somewhat ad hoc way I think if you were
able to combine you know bacon label
inference with with with Jeff you'd
probably get best of both worlds and be
able to write information flow
applications with less annotation burden
but did still have to be very careful
about how you construct your application
because you might not have to write down
types but you still have to program in
this somewhat difficult style so you do
get something by by committing to
information flow but you mentioned in
Delhi bjs what amazing example my
curiousity of approach approached
pitbull horse in charge of it to solicit
feedback from the practicalities yes we
have so um I don't have put it I don't
have clearance so I can't really talk to
these guys but but my my advisor does
and so he's uh yeah I don't know I can't
tell you so much about it but right and
yeah I suppose I mean super boring so
from what I've heard via my advisor they
really you know they really think that
being able to do fine grained access
control is the right thing and they want
to be able to do this in some rival way
they think that they would like to have
more features or things like RSS feeds
and better searching and stuff like that
which we don't have in our application
right now so that's something that we're
we're trying to build in and so in mike
is at least in relatively close contact
with intel appear device
browser no no they don't have this
problem because they have complete
isolation so you know chocolate a
top-secret guy can only see top secret
stuff and yes log it's actually they
have maybe even separate machines on the
same desktop alert cadet that are
connected to different systems URL by
here if they want to do something with
fine grain access control about this
yeah okay in this case it may not be too
bad because within this we say within
the CIA you could require every machine
to run a beep enabled browser and you
okay so there you know you know whole
history of multi-level security you're
not going back to the orange yes yes so
can you do all of what they require by
their standards or multi-level security
on the same system I believe so yeah I
mean they certainly I don't know if I
mean they the orange book mandates a
certain kind of enforcement mechanism as
well it requires operating system level
separations and so on so we're trying to
say that you know maybe you those kinds
of separations are ad hoc that you could
actually do it in the application and
verify that it did the right thing and
get the same properties so in some ways
what we're proposing is not in
compliance with orange book because
you're similar a behavior of the
application what is running on
increasing your model yes and yeah I
gave the operating systems that you can
verify it all the way down to the
hardware you simply opens a whole nother
channel of the time i think i believe
the orange book requires that that
applications are not cleared to handle
multiple classification levels so we're
fundamentally we're trying to propose a
new model in which you say you know
orange book is sort of ad hoc we can
give you the same sort of properties but
in a more principled way by letting you
track information flows throughout the
system so maybe you do it in the
operating system and then you track
flows throughout the application as well
quick was that you're sort of your proof
thing that you get the security right in
an application it's very much dependent
or the application executing the way you
expected different so since there are
many levels of software below the
application yes okay we can't really
ensure that well unless you can yeah yes
yes yes agreed yes crystal the poor
subset of s evening sound just outside
this course upset that could be on
sounder dangerous I should be worried
worried about when I use it so what
we've proved is so this it's basically a
dependently type system f we actually
didn't show you about show you this
stuff but it's dependent types with
substructure types tracks take changes
as well so we don't model this
multi-tier thing at all so this
compilation strategy to stick things in
the database is just it's just systems
work we haven't actually proved that
that are you know compilation strategy
is correct or anything the the other
thing that we have model is that se
links has or links itself has a sort of
message passing model of concurrency
which is in a it's in the language but
it's not fully baked out that's the
direction in which the links guys want
to go but are so we don't handle that at
this point